six one seven eight three zero 47 50
we're continuing to take calls and we
will go next to our callers from the
seven one eight area code caller from
seven one eight is that uh is that
Brooklyn uh
well in New York seven one eight
actually covers I'm in the Bronx right
now but seven eight is Brooklyn Bronx
and queens in New York City right my old
neighborhood all right what's on your
mind and you know tell us your name as
well uh my name is Karim
I was actually just watching uh
scaramouche II talked to Cuomo my
question was actually going to be like
what sources you use because I you know
I try to like watch as many obviously
you and the Young Turks and I want to
CNN and everything but yeah you know
it's tricky I feel like it's just hard
to get good news I get outside of you
know centralized online sources because
you know I watch CNN and they'll play
clips and you know Trump will complain
that CNN is unfair
all these people say gens unfair and I
feel like they're overly fair I feel
like CNN pays people like Jeffery Lord
and Andrew Bauer and all these people
are go in there and basically say you
know in this you know defend the
indefensible you're on a daily night you
know and as critical as I think they are
they're really not critical enough even
though I think the current topic in
today's obviously the health care bill
and in the past thing of it and I think
scaramouche he basically told you know
he's telling America hey just trust
Donald Trump it yeah yeah yeah foresight
into the future and everything will pay
up again I guess the same guy who didn't
see the the housing crisis two years
before it crash so how do you feel about
you know McCain coming back and everyone
obviously it's a brave thing from Akane
to you know come back with a brain
cancer but I took some flak because I
had many comment online where yeah he
did that when he came back a rich
powerful you know okay wait how arraign
hold on one second if I may know cancer
surgery you got a couple did you want to
know about what news sources I trust or
what I think
about John McCain coming back yeah it
was two questions yeah my first yeah my
first one did yeah what's here what's
here okay you you actually let me answer
the second one first great that McCain
came back sad that he has this diagnosis
I think that he may be going in the
direction I completely disagree with in
terms of the substance of this Obamacare
repeal but great that he's back
kind of ironic he came back he's got
great health care and he participated in
a process that may lead to tons of
people losing health care what sources
to trust here's the thing go as much as
you can to the original source so first
of all if you pull up a new a so-called
news website and they've basically
rewritten an article that hopefully
they're at least honest enough to link
to from a primary news source go to the
primary news source there's a lot of
these websites that just are rewriting
news do we as a policy don't use those
on the show deliberately sometimes there
might be some you know oversight we do a
lot of stories with a lot of sourcing
but the idea is we're going to primary
sources secondly there is no one source
that is always the holy grail of
accuracy but we've seen over time that
you can generally if you're trying to
get an understanding of the facts on the
ground you can go to reuters you can go
to the Associated Press New York Times
and Washington Post
despite Donald Trump talking about them
it's fake news they've done very good
critical investigative reporting of this
current administration that they've done
really good reporting and I consider
them to be trustworthy sources so it's
less Pat I think about some list of real
propaganda and fake news or something
like that but of understanding am I
looking at a primary source that has
spoken directly to the sources they're
quoting or are we looking at rewrites of
articles done by another media outlet
and then separately from that is this a
news outlet like Infowars for example
which has parotid just completely made
up and debunked claims and it's it's you
can't even really call it a new source
at all sure it's a tough thing to
balance and I guess you do have to have
some trust in the world but you also
have to look at the reputation of the
news source you have to look at you know
it
using anonymous sources or secret
sources what have you so anytime you
want to check out the sources we had
them in the YouTube clips for the story
as well yeah we're always open about
what we're using as a baseline we are
transparent in terms of where we are
sourcing the story and you can see that
you know if you're listening to the
podcast or watching on TV or listening
on the radio you can go over to the
YouTube channel and in that clip for
whatever story you heard you will see
our sources listed alright thanks for
the call much appreciated always great
to hear from our New York viewers and
listeners